for more storylines to go on our
countdown of the top 30 to watch for
2019 and this one focuses on the city of
the Three Rivers can the Pittsburgh
Steelers recover from all of the drama
all of the acrimony the trade of Antonio
Brown the departure of Le'Veon Bell and
the potential improvement of teams in
the division like the Baltimore Ravens
and the Cleveland Browns what will the
Steelers do in the aftermath of what was
a very disappointing season will they
come together will they take on that us
against the world mentality will it
cause every member of the organization
to do everything possible check every
box put in extra time do all the little
things necessary to be as prepared as
they can be to come out of the gates
aggressively and win football games and
prove all the doubters wrong and show
lay beyond bell Antonio Brown and anyone
else out there who would have a problem
with the way the Steelers do business
that the Steelers are still one of the
best organizations in all of football
you know they've been caught now by the
New England Patriots with six Super Bowl
championships Steelers have six Patriots
have six and the Patriots desperately
would like to get to number seven the
Steelers if they truly can't come
together and if they can find a way to
turn all those negatives from last
season into a positive they could be one
of those teams that the Patriots need to
worry about the Patriots haven't had to
worry much about the Pittsburgh Steelers
in recent years and the season begins
with a visit from Pittsburgh to New
England what better way to put everyone
on notice that the Steelers are back
then to go up there that first Sunday
night of the season and upend the
defending Super Bowl champions and let
everyone know it's a new time it's a new
age it's a new era for one of the old
guard teams in the NFL that is trying to
go back a step rally regroup and press
forward in that race that they're having
with the New England Patriots for Super
Bowl trophy number seven
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports